en los vídeos pasados trabajamos con
lentes convexos en donde dibujamos
ciertos rayos paralelos y otros que
pasaban por el punto focal para
encontrar cuál sería la imagen
resultante al otro lado de la lente pero
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar una relación algebraica que
involucre la distancia del objeto al
lente la distancia del objeto al lente
la distancia de la imagen al lente y la
distancia focal que llamamos a efe para
ordenarles la angustia de verme dibujar
estas líneas rectas aquí ya tengo lista
una imagen y pueden ver que esta flecha
es el objeto original estos dos puntos
son los focos y aquí se encuentra la
imagen real resultante ahora permite
etiquetar algunos de los elementos de
esta imagen está la distancia del objeto
al lente es esta misma distancia que se
encuentra acá sólo que está desplazada
por lo que esto va a ser de iu
la distancia de la imagen al lente es
esta que está señalada aquí por lo que
aquí escribo d
y obviamente aquí están nuestros focos
este es efe y este también es
efe ahora quiero encontrar una relación
entre todos estos elementos y para
hacerlo voy a dibujar algunos triángulos
aquí la estrategia va a ser encontrar
triángulos similares para ver si
encontramos relaciones o razones entre
todos estos elementos lo primero que voy
a hacer es re dibujar o invertir este
triángulo que se encuentra acá este de
acá de manera que me quede en esta otra
sección voy a tratar de hacerlo con todo
cuidado voy a partir de acá
este va a pasar por el foco
va a seguir así
de manera que este triángulo que estoy
dibujando en morado
es el mismo pero invertido que se
encuentra del lado izquierdo
por lo que esta otra parte este lado
también va a ser de oh bueno ya tenemos
estos triángulos así ahora si podemos
hacer algo interesante podemos
relacionar este triángulo de acá con
este otro triángulo de acá podremos ver
que son similares y también
encontraremos algunas razones para
mostrar que este triángulo de acá es
similar a este triángulo de acá y una
vez que establezcamos esto podemos
encontrar las relaciones entre todos
estos elementos lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es demostrar que estos dos
triángulos son similares y vemos que
este ángulo de acá es el mismo que el
ángulo que se encuentra acá y esto viene
de que d
es paralelo a de y por esta misma razón
el ángulo que se forma aquí
va a ser el mismo ángulo que se forma en
esta otra parte ya que podemos ver que
esta línea de en medio es transversal y
intersecta a estas dos líneas paralelas
y es por eso que estos dos ángulos van a
ser iguales y podemos aplicar
exactamente el mismo argumento en este
otro lado donde tenemos estos ángulos
que voy a poner en color naranja este
ángulo de acá va a ser el mismo que el
ángulo que se encuentra de este lado y
por lo que vemos estos tres ángulos son
iguales a los ángulos que se encuentran
aquí arriba por lo que estos dos
triángulos son similares los señalamos
este triángulo y este triángulo
que estos dos son triángulos similares
similares
esto la razón la proporción entre los
datos de los triángulos serán iguales es
decir
este d es opuesto este ángulo en verde y
esta de ahí también va a ser opuesta a
este ángulo en verde que son iguales por
lo que la proporción de o entre de y va
a ser equivalente y aquí permítanme
agregar algunas etiquetas a la
proporción que se encuentra en este lado
vamos a ponerlo en qué color será un
carlos color café la proporción que se
encuentra en este lado de aquí en este
lado la voy a llamar a y la que se
encuentra en este otro lado
en este otro lado la voy a llamar be
es opuesto a este ángulo naranja que
escribí aquí
el lado opuesto de este ángulo naranja
en este otro triángulo es b por lo que a
va a tener la misma proporción que ve
así que tenemos que a tiene la misma
razón sobre b de lo que d
la tiene con respecto a de iu y esto es
bastante interesante ya que pudimos
relacionar estas dos longitudes
arbitrarias y las conectamos mediante la
distancia focal
relacionarlos con la distancia focal lo
que voy a hacer es tomar
ive
está en el mismo triángulo donde se
encuentra la distancia focal aquí voy a
remarcar este triángulo que me interesa
ahora con rojo
lente hacia la distancia focal
este elemento de la altura
y remarcando el lado
este es el triángulo que ahora me va a
interesar analizar y vamos a compararlo
con este otro triángulo que también voy
a resaltar en este color pero que se
encuentra de este otro lado
involucrando la imagen del objeto el
lado ve también
ahora quiero mostrar que estos dos
triángulos son similares
estos ángulos en blanco que estoy
dibujando acá son iguales ya que se
forman entre líneas que se intersectan y
podemos tener el mismo argumento en
otros ángulos interiores aquí puedo
decir que hay ángulos rectos en este
triángulo y en este otro triángulo y si
tenemos dos ángulos que son iguales pues
el tercer ángulo en ambos triángulos va
a ser el mismo ya que aquí hay un ángulo
de 90 grados aquí hay un ángulo que es
igual a este y aquí también hay un
ángulo de 90 grados por lo que este
ángulo de acá que voy a poner que será
en color rosa este ángulo de acá va a
ser el mismo que voy a tener en este
ángulo de acá
otra forma de verlo es imaginar o darse
cuenta de que este lado del lente es
paralelo a este lado que se forma con la
imagen y esta línea intersecta estas dos
otras líneas paralelas por lo que estos
ángulos internos van a ser iguales
finalmente aquí estamos demostrando que
este triángulo de acá es similar al
triángulo que se encuentra en esta otra
parte y ahora sí ya con esto podemos
encontrar las relaciones de los
elementos que estamos buscando vamos a
realizar la misma inferencia de que a
tiene la misma proporción que ve que
señalamos aquí y esta proporción va a
ser igual a como efe en este caso este
lado que es f el lado opuesto a este
ángulo rosa está efe
va a tener la misma proporción que tiene
este otro lado opuesto de este ángulo
rosa que se encuentra aquí este lado qué
distancia o cuánto va a medir este lado
bueno sabemos que esta distancia
completa es de y sabemos que esta parte
es efe por lo que esta va a ser de menos
f entonces la proporción es de la
distancia focal con respecto a la
distancia de la imagen menos la
distancia focal entonces quedamos que
esto es de i - es esta distancia
acá y ahora sólo nos resta hacer un poco
de álgebra vamos a reescribir los
elementos que nos interesan aquí ya que
esto es igual a esto y eso es igual a
esto podemos decir que estos dos son
iguales por lo que escribo la distancia
del objeto en relación con la distancia
de la imagen
es igual a la distancia focal entre la
distancia de la imagen menos la
distancia focal hagamos una
multiplicación cruzada voy a multiplicar
esto por estos elementos de acá y esto
por estos elementos de acá entonces me
va a quedar que la distancia al objeto
por la distancia de la imagen menos la
distancia del objeto por la distancia
focal
efe va a ser igual a la distancia de la
imagen por la distancia focal
por efe a ambos lados de la ecuación voy
a sumar de a f o la distancia del objeto
por efe me va a quedar distancia del
objeto por distancia de la imagen igual
a la distancia de la imagen por la
distancia focal menos la distancia del
objeto no perdón más que bueno que me
acordé estamos sumando más la distancia
del objeto por el punto focal o la
distancia focal aquí puedo factorizar
efe entonces me quedaría distancia del
objeto por distancia de la imagen igual
a la distancia de la imagen más la
distancia del objeto todo multiplicado
por la distancia focal vamos a dividir a
ambos lados entre f
teo de i / efe igual a la distancia de
la imagen más la distancia del objeto
por efe / efe estas dos se van a
cancelar
dando la distancia del objeto por
distancia de la imagen
/ efe igual a distancia de la imagen más
la distancia del objeto finalmente vamos
a dividir todo entre distancia del
objeto por distancia de la imagen aquí
divido esto 1 / de o de y lo mismo hago
en este otro lado
nos queda 1 / efe igual voy a
multiplicar esto por ambos términos me
queda de iu entre de o por de i + d
/
de o por d
de estos elementos puede anular estos
dos y estos dos de acá donde ya
finalmente me quedaría con la siguiente
fórmula
1 / efe / la distancia focal es igual a
1 / la distancia del objeto más 1 / la
distancia de la imagen y aquí tenemos la
fórmula que nos va a relacionar todos
los elementos de interés en este caso de
los lentes convexos y que sinceramente
usamos un método bastante interesante
para encontrarla